[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
perú que celebra elecciones
presidenciales el balotaje el próximo 6
de junio entre dos candidatos populistas
keiko fujimori y pedro castillo saludo
ya en este estudio list el quirós
historiador especializado en perú buenos
días lee cel
para josé zorrilla politóloga del
instituto de altos estudios de américa
latina' bienvenida maria jose buenos
dias cercanos y en dúplex gustavo pastor
investigador del observatorio político
de américa latina y américa latina y el
caribe buenos días señor pastor díaz y
muchas gracias carlos con mi presión
perú elección entre dos extremos hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
la inestabilidad política en perú lleva
años llenando portadas de periódicos
ahora el país elige presidente en un
duelo reñido entre dos extremos que
tienen un punto en común un duelo de
ultraconservadores tanto el izquierdista
radical pedro castillo como la ultra
derechista keiko fujimori rechazan la
igualdad de género el matrimonio
homosexual y el aborto así que es una
certeza ya tenemos clara es que el
próximo 6 de junio fecha del balotaje
perú tendrá un presidente populista y
conservador independientemente de quién
gane y otra evidencia más en forma de
dato casi un tercio de la población en
perú no puede cubrir sus necesidades
básicas así lo dice el instituto
nacional de estadística la pandemia
incrementó en diez puntos porcentuales
la pobreza empujando a tres millones de
nuevos pobres a la precariedad total en
el país repasemos algunas portadas que
nos deja esta campaña electoral diario
gestión
castillo 44 por ciento keiko 41 por
ciento en un primer simulacro previo a
la votación otras encuestas recientes
como ésta de expresó dan prácticamente
un empate técnico entre ambos candidatos
correo
se hace eco de lo que llama ola de
agresiones a periodistas por parte del
entorno de la candidatura de pedro
castillo el comercio se hacía eco esta
semana de la matanza terrorista
atribuida al sendero luminoso que ha
dejado 16 muertos en el país y que eleva
al máximo la tensión en está polarizada
campaña luego les preguntaré sobre el
impacto de esta noticia pero antes les
pregunto a breve pendiente y a los tres
esta campaña tan polarizada entre
extremos responde es el reflejo de la
sociedad peruana hoy en día dicen me
parece que es más bien el reflejo de una
sociedad que está desesperada por una
situación que vive de que la sota desde
hace más de hace varios años la
inseguridad ciudadana por ejemplo lo que
va a llevar más un voto hacia keiko la
corrupción de todos los partidos
políticos de toda la clase política lo
cual hace que por ejemplo pedro castillo
haya surgido como personaje alternativo
y recordemos antes que nada que el perú
atraviesa una crisis muy importante esta
crisis política de un vacío de poder
desde el 2018
una crisis económica el pib ha caído en
el 2020 11 por ciento y la crisis
sanitaria porque como sabemos también el
país es uno de los lugares donde ha
vivido la cob y ha hecho estragos
considerables entonces todo esto puede
explicar estas formas de polarización
del electorado
maria jose si bueno carlos yo creo que
estas elecciones presidenciales han
estado marcadas por un fuerte clima
político y social bastante turbulento
recordemos que en estos últimos cuatro
años hemos tenido cuatro diferentes
presidentes y yo creo que esto se
evidenció en la primera vuelta más que
una polarización se evidenció aún una
suerte de fragmentación la pulverización
de la representación en el congreso y
ahora recientemente a nivel presidencial
es algo nuevo en perú y como dice el
profesor de la universidad del pacifico
alberto vergara
intenta explicar esta pulverización ya
que para él eso se debe una a causa de
una bancarrota moral debido a que
durante la pandemia los políticos
estuvieron arrancando la banda
presidencial y bueno y esto tuvo como
resultado según la onpe a un 100 por
ciento castillo con un primer puesto con
un 18 por ciento del total los votos
keiko en un segundo puesto con un 13 por
ciento es decir con 2 millones de
peruanos que han votado por ella y para
contextualizar esto un poco en 2016
keiko les pasó a primera vuelta con un
39% de votos es decir con 6 millones de
peruanos es decir que en cope río en
estos 5 años 4 millones de electorados
entonces para mí yo pienso que más que
una polarización lo que está sucediendo
es una fragmentación del voto y pues
esto se ve justamente en el antiguo
tonel antifujimorismo el anticomunismo
etcétera los antis que funcionan mucho
en esta campaña se lo vamos a preguntar
también al profesor gustavo si esta
campaña polarizada responde el reflejo
de una sociedad polarizada señor pastor
lo que se refleja una sociedad
fuertemente crowley
y polarizada en diversos aspectos
primero digamos el aspecto de
desigualdades socioeconómicas
un beneficio económico una proyección
ideológica entre lo que quieren cambiar
el modelo neoliberal y lo que no quiere
y quiere mantener registrado con una
proyección geográfica porque digamos la
lista lima contra todo el resto del país
también en el fondo y yo creo que esta
polarización política responde por sobre
toda la distinta la grave crisis
económica social y sanitaria y política
que ha vivido el país en los últimos
años yo creo que esa es la clave y ha
habido una caída económica digamos del
10% de la población ha pasado a la
pobreza ahora y 30 por ciento de pobre
los hay y yo creo que pues los
candidatos del centro que por lo general
kim ganaban las elecciones en realidad
no han tenido ninguna opción en mis
prescripciones
tremendo lo de los candidatos del centro
claro porque si hablamos de dos
candidatos extremos que pasan la segunda
vuelta que ha pasado con el perú con los
candidatos moderados ha sido el gran
fracaso es el sí un gran fracaso pero
que se debe a esta en estos años en los
que se ha manifestado la corrupción a un
nivel que ya es insoportable para la
población peruana no sabes o quizás la
corrupción es histórica pero en estos
últimos años como lo decía maria jose
estamos en un momento en que es ha sido
una pelea por el poder de la mayoría de
los de los partidos políticos y de las
personas de los partidos políticos que
por ejemplo si nos fijamos en la última
el último congreso 168 congresistas
involucrados en temas de investigaciones
judiciales es decir más del 52 por
ciento de los parlamentarios o sea están
incluidos están jueces
los presidentes que los ex presidentes
que han sido procesados también de
justicia todo esto ha dado una imagen
tan negativa de la clase política
tradicional que los partidos políticos
pero nos pesan se han visto no esté
completamente desacreditado durante esta
campaña nos haya se ha buscado como
generalmente una opción distinta bueno
de la tradicional y de los propios
candidatos porque la propia keiko
fujimori sobre ella planea prende la
sombra del blanqueo de capitales en
anteriores campañas de la mano de poder
brace y que incluso se expone a prisión
sí pero que podría llevar la inmunidad
no esto llega a la presidencia no
entendemos llevarse a la inmunidad y por
otro lado si nos fijamos bien también en
todo este proceso los procesos
judiciales son muy lentos para estas
personas es decir que hay
investigaciones o investigaciones que no
culminan porque estamos con un problema
de corrupción también entonces eso va a
hacer que sea más lento y por el momento
nadie ha sido condenado abiertamente es
decir han sido procesados anterior
encarcelamiento durante el tiempo de las
investigaciones pero no tenemos unos
dictámenes finales hasta ahora entonces
eso también puede beneficiar a que
maríajosé keiko ya lo intentado en otras
veces quizás esta sea la la gran
diferencia con el otro candidato con
castillo pero quizá esto esta vez por
los miedos que infunde castillo sea la
que más cerca lo tiene por aglutinar
digamos esos apoyos de la derecha y del
centroderecha aglutina ahora más apoyos
keiko es la diferencia con otras veces
claro recordemos que keiko ya ha
postulado en dos ocasiones en el 2011 y
2016 y yo pienso que la diferencia ahora
es que justamente eso tiene el apoyo de
las derechas recordemos también que el
tercer puesto del señor lópez aliaga por
el partido renovación popular y el señor
hernando de soto por avanza país ya le
han dado su respaldo a keiko fujimori es
decir supuestamente también va tendría
que tener también sus votantes
asimismo el premio nobel de literatura
mario vargas llosa también le ha dado su
respaldo y recientemente le había
invitado justamente a una conferencia y
su fundación internacional por la
democracia para hablar justamente de la
democracia de la libertad etcétera y
creo que también es interesante
acotar la en términos de ciencias
sociales etcétera
el apoyo que tienen es el que ha
brindado ciertos miembros de la
selección peruana a la candidatura de
keiko fujimori creo que es bastante
habría que profundizar un poquito más
ahí pero bueno creo que la pregunta es
si al final estos apoyos van habana nada
van a ser suficientes para que keiko
vuelva a la primera primera la primera
presidenta mujer del perú porque aunque
coinciden en conservadurismo es verdad
que las trayectorias de ambos candidatos
son muy distintas
hemos estábamos hablando de keiko pero
el maestro izquierdista pedro castillo
era un auténtico desconocido incluso
dentro de perú hasta hace poco a qué se
debe ese ascenso fulgurante el bisel se
debe a que nuevamente no es algo tan
desconocidas dentro de la trayectoria
pero no recordemos que alberto fujimori
en 1990 era también un perfecto
desconocido así más o menos estamos en
algo paralelo a fujimori también tuvo un
acceso fulgurante el pedro castillo es
un maestro de la región del norte de
cajamarca de los andes del norte una
región por cierto muy movilizada en
estos últimos años en todos los temas
anti extractivistas no por defensa del
medio ambiente la defensa contra las
empresas extranjeras mineras en
particular también ya ha sido un
sindicalista del sindicato de profesores
del perú que tiene una larga trayectoria
o sea que está muy implicado
políticamente y se había presentado en
particular en las movilizaciones del
2017 no este está muy movilizado en esas
en esos momentos entonces si tiene una
trayectoria no es un total desconocido
pero últimamente él representa y eso es
lo que ha capitalizado
perú rural al perú que no el que no es
el de lima el centralizado de limeño un
profesor
por eso el lápiz no es un emblema él
quiere incentivar la educación en un año
en donde os hasta ahora los niños no han
regresado a las escuelas durante la
pandemia no no están sobre todo en el
campo han sufrido mucho y también es un
hombre que representa a todo lo que nos
algo quiere representar una alternativa
a los políticos corruptos entonces todo
esto ha participado en ese en ese
crecimiento de su popularidad en que
este pedro castillo en esta segunda
vuelta representa maria jose esa
fractura entre lima y el perú rural sí
sí sí por supuesto pero como decíamos
pero castillo quizás ya no era no era
conocido para la clase política limeña
pero sí a nivel regional se hizo
conocido en 2017 por las protestas los
maestros que justamente estaban pidiendo
mejora de salarios y limitar las
evaluaciones para los docentes
etcétera me gustaría contar un poco de
lo que dijo lizette con la última
encuesta de lepe que salió este domingo
en donde se les pregunta a los votantes
de castillo por qué votarían por
castillo y de este porcentaje en la
mitad el 40 y 48 por ciento respondió
que es porque casi representa un cambio
que el país necesita y en un segundo
momento en un 29 por ciento de estos de
sus votantes dijo porque rechazó y
rechaza que el fujimorismo vuelve al
poder de nuevo volvemos a ver esta
noción de antiguo 'no y vamos a hacer
una previa pausa y en unos instantes
seguimos analizando las elecciones de
perú aquí en primera plana
[Música]
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven la noticia una mirada
diferente a la actualidad
vídeos que no verá en ningún otro sitio
los observadores en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado
tenemos que pensar quién se beneficia
mujeres que protagonizan la agenda
política económica social cultural del
mundo han conversado con los periodistas
de france 24 en español y no es una moda
pasajera el feminismo con la forma de
ver la realidad
seguimos aquí en primera plana
analizando la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones en perú entre castillo
fujimori que se va a celebrar el próximo
6 de junio lo hacemos con lis el quirós
historiador especializado en perú maría
josé zorrilla politólogo del instituto
de altos estudios de américa latina y
gustavo pastor e investigador político
le quería preguntar el señor pastor esta
semana conocíamos esa matanza atribuida
al grupo sendero luminoso que deja al
menos 16 muertos una noticia sin duda
que ha cambiado a lo mejor un poco el
discurso normal de esta campaña señor
pastor como debemos interpretar esta
matanza en plena campaña y qué efecto
puede tener de cara a la elección en
realidad diríamos crimen que ha ocurrido
en esta zona no por el contrario entre
2020 y 2021 no habían habido 17
atentados armados 25 asesinatos 14
secuestros no no porque lo que pasa es
que hay una un ala de sendero luminoso
lo que se llama el partido entre visto
un disfrazado comunista del perú que
está dirigido por los hermanos quispe
palomino que están digamos siembran el
terror en esa zona y
están muy metidos con el tema el tráfico
ha sonado mucho en el perú porque
digamos que los aprendes salvarlo ha
seguido en plena campaña de segunda
vuelta no sobre todo que hay un
candidato que está acusado de tener
lazos con el terrorismo que eso ha
llamado mucho la atención los campos han
empezado si vamos a usar se lo que una
responsabilidad pero digamos de que las
implicancias que se pueden tener ese
link directivamente que algunos
ciudadanos medios por el miedo no voten
por uno o por otro candidato defendiendo
pues que versiones y que teorías piensen
de quién es el responsable de todo esto
y bueno claro a nivel internacional lo
que nos deja así un poco a técnicos casi
todos los líderes de sendero luminoso
están presos pero hablamos de sus
remanentes hasta qué punto siguen
activos siguen activos que poder tienen
esos remanentes actualmente dentro de
perú el cero que los remanentes están
limitados políticamente creo que es algo
lo que sucede en este valle en los
valles del apurimac ln y el mantaro que
se llaman otras la región del vrae
es que está como lo ha señalado ha
gustado pastor es un espacio que está
dominado eso es una región dominada por
el narcotráfico donde el tema yo creo
que ahí hay una gran semejanza con lo
que ha pasado en colombiano sabe que
queda esa es la remanencia más bien de
esos espacios donde el estado no puede
ingresar donde están dominados por estos
grupos que son a la vez políticos
paramilitares y que actúan todavía en
coordinación con el actor narcotráfico
están protegiendo ese espacio creo que
los atentados también son una manera de
señalar que no quieren y no van a querer
la que el estado venga y ponga este css
y salí e instale un control sobre sobre
esas regiones entonces es aprovechar
estos momentos que estamos focalizados
este en las elecciones y para actuar y
aquí salen desde ya en el fuego y dar
miedo y temor y además es cierto que eso
va a dar la memoria de lo que
lo que vivió el perú en los años 80 no
sé si este episodio va a tener impacto
en la demoscópica en las encuestas de
momento lo que decían hemos visto antes
alguna 44% pastor 41 por ciento keiko
otros hablaban de que keiko ido
recortando la ventaja que inicialmente
sí que tenía pastor después de la
primera vuelta hasta qué punto tienen
credibilidad las demoscópicas en perú
para josé bueno confiarnos más o menos
depende dependen porque pues claro hubo
una pequeña controversia las últimas
elecciones porque nadie pudo prever el
fenómeno castillo
pero si en total hay algunas hay buenas
encuestadoras como el atún ipsos pero
más o menos las tendencias las
tendencias se mantiene el castillo va al
alza y parece que el antivoto no ha
surtido el efecto deseado y keiko me
parece que ésta está un poco a la baja
de 0.8 pero bueno siempre tenemos el
margen de error de más/menos 3 por
ciento en algunas hablan de empate
técnico últimamente después de esa
ventaja de castillo otras decían que yo
había recortado en los últimos tiempos
no sé a qué atribuye el profesor pastor
esta evolución de la campaña señor
pastor
esta evolución tiene que ver mucho sobre
todo digamos yo creo con los errores y
los aciertos que están teniendo los dos
candidatos en campaña pues pero castillo
empezó con una larga diferente más o no
tenía 20 por ciento desde el punto de
diferencia pero ha cometido una serie de
errores que eso pero le ha ido pasando
factura
ahora en estas últimas semanas en la
tratado de solucionar esos errores sobre
todo puede deslindar con los lazos con
el terrorismo y con la corrupción que
hay en su partido y puede dotarse de un
equipo técnico más solvente para los
debates eco por su lado pues es una
candidata con mucha experiencia keiko es
este es su tercera segunda vuelta en los
últimos 15 años entonces por muchos
errores no ha cometido sin embargo ya
vienen pues con una mochila muy pensada
con todos estos problemas de corrupción
de lado de activos y su responsabilidad
contra la inestabilidad política del
perú los últimos cinco hola yo creo que
quien va a ganar va a sentir doble
comunicar mejor no quien se resiente
digamos como el menos malo y también que
pueda sobrevivir digamos a toda la
campaña sucia que se viene en estos
últimos días en el perú pues todo puede
pasar en una semana no se sabe
quien vaya a ganar y yo creo que el
debate presidencial de este domingo bajo
control importante y que los ciudadanos
indecisos vayan tomando una decisión por
un bando proyecto
además que lo que sea lo que se añada
gustado pastores que no solo keiko
fujimori tiene una experiencia que no
tiene castillo pero también tiene unos
medios económicos muchísimo más amplios
no y el apoyo es lo que se ha señalado
estos últimos días de la prensa por
ejemplo no que está también es un apoyo
indirecto bastante directo para que por
eso también esa diferencia que había de
porcentual se ha ido disminuyendo
también por ese efecto y ambos
candidatos son opuestos a derechos
sociales como el matrimonio igualitario
el aborto y no son impulsores desde
luego ni del feminismo ni de la igualdad
con este panorama que dicen las minorías
del país las asociaciones de derechos
humanos porque afirma el voto es
obligatorio si por supuesto y como
estábamos comentando anteriormente yo
creo que al final los que los que
determinan perry no son justamente estos
movimientos o estas agrupaciones pero
derechos humanos por ejemplo no se desee
ver a la mente movimientos feministas
flora tristán etcétera
por ejemplo movimientos que están a
favor de los derechos de las poblaciones
indígenas y por el momento me parece que
no se han pronunciado están manteniendo
una postura neutra porque en realidad no
no hay ninguna mejora en ningunas
opciones
exactamente y bueno eso me recuerda que
verónica mendoza que era la candidata
también de izquierda pero una izquierda
que llamaremos izquierda que lo llamaba
exactamente pues al principio tuvo esas
reticencias y luego de las negociaciones
bueno se fue desplegando a
a pedro castillo pero también hay que
señalar que pedro castillo
a diferencia de keiko fujimori sostiene
que puede haber una y referendos y para
ver estas temáticas también o sea no fue
totalmente se ha ido evolucionando
cuando porque esa esa crítica no la ha
abierto diciendo pero podemos dejar esto
a que el pueblo peruano se exprese a
través de un referendo por ejemplo casi
un tercio de la población en perú no
puede cubrir sus necesidades básicas lo
dice el instituto nacional de
estadística- la pandemia incrementó 10
puntos porcentuales la pobreza empujando
a 3 millones de peruanos nuevos a la
precariedad total cuál será la receta de
ambos candidatos para encarar esta
realidad que asola el país porque son
recetas muy distintas no sí por supuesto
yo creo que uno de los retos que van a
tener que encarar es justamente esta
legitimidad para gobernar un país
dividido / bueno por esta recientemente
por estas elecciones por el odio por el
anti y sobre todo como dice es la
pandemia el proceso de vacunación y
también en una posible crisis económica
ligada a la pandemia y bueno yo creo que
al final lo que ambos van a tener que no
caer sobre todo es algo que yo quisiera
que ambos
desearan no caer ese no caer en un
populismo autoritario ya sea de
izquierda o de derecha
vamos a preguntarle el señor pastor
cuáles son los principales retos que
tendrá que encarar el vencedor de la
segunda vuelta y próximo presidente del
país
el próximo presidente pues va a tener la
cosa muy difícil en realidad no porque
pues va a tener que lidiar con la crisis
sanitaria con la crisis económica con la
crisis social con la crisis política el
cribo digamos se mantiene como uno de
los países más afectados por la pandemia
no en cantidad de muertos sobre todo la
economía peruana ha caído un 11 por
ciento en 2020 no en el ámbito político
todavía peor porque el ámbito político
digamos es cualquiera quien sea quien
gane las elecciones se va a enfrentar a
un parlamento que está fragmentado
y compuesto de muchos novatos y de mucho
populismo y claro van a tener que pasar
alianzas que ninguno tiene una mayoría
y claro lo peor es que lleva al seguir
yo creo aumentando el descontento de los
peruanos con su clase política y con la
democracia no es posible digamos que
tenemos el perú en los próximos años no
logré salir desde la política y la
confrontación entre los poderes del
estado gracias en el pastor bueno lo
está apuntando al señor pastor la
inestabilidad política un mal que hemos
visto en perú del que hemos hablado
muchísimo
últimos años y que parece que no se va a
solucionar tampoco con esta elección no
no
bueno ese es el gran desafío de la
persona que gane las elecciones
primeramente sanear este tema de la
política peruana que castillo propone el
referendo sobre la nueva constitución de
ahí hay muchos movimientos pienso que lo
que acaba de suceder en chile por
ejemplo sería una gran ejemplo a seguir
en el perú no sea proponer y
verdaderamente cambiar estructuralmente
de manera de dar a la población
confianza en esta clase política también
de limitar no está esta corrupción y
trabajar creo que es el primer el primer
paso que debe dar cualquiera el próximo
próximo presidente del perú pero estamos
frente también a ese riesgo de caer en
el autoritarismo nos hace que eso
también hay que ser muy vigilantes no sé
si quieren algún reto más para el
próximo presidente del perú bueno como
yo le había mencionado sobre todo
esta legitimidad de poder gobernar un
país que está dividido está está
fragmentado en diversos y en diversos
sectores de la población en diversos
maneras de querer llevar el estado y
pues sobre todo con la pandemia a
superar esta crisis
bueno pues ha sido muy interesante lo
conoceremos conoceremos esta respuesta
el día 6 y a partir de que conoceremos
si se pueden reconciliar esos dos perú
es decir en lima con las provincias
según quién salga habrá un trabajo
también de reconciliar a la otra parte
no muy importante muy importante y
pienso sobre todo no olvidar a aquellos
que han vivido y está esto periodo de
manera brutal los a que están esos
pobres tres millones de personas los
olvidados las personas que quedan
dolidas en sus familias porque han
perdido familiares en fin hay que
primero sanar también esa herida que
tenemos me quedo ya sintiendo muchísimas
gracias así un placer lissl maría josé
gustavo lo sabremos como el desenlace el
próximo día 6 en este balotaje de las
elecciones en perú a todos ustedes
muchísimas gracias
y hasta la próxima semana en primera
plana
[Música]